Сотні спортсменів у Білорусі підтримали протести проти фальсифікацій на виборах президента.
Під відкритим листом з вимогою провести повторне голосування залишили підписи понад 1600 спортсменів.
Багатьох з них переслідують за активну громадянську позицію. Зокрема, Андрія Кравченка, срібного призера Олімпійських ігор у Пекіні в десятиборстві,
після підписання відкритого листа звільнили з КДБ, позбавили вислуги років та місця в національній команді.
Чимало білоруських спортсменів, які зіткнулися з тиском влади, сподівалися,
що Міжнародний олімпійський комітет відреагує на те, що відбувається у Білорусі. І от нарешті.
Міжнародний олімпійський комітет дійшов висновку, що нинішнє керівництво Білорусі
не захищало білоруських спортсменів достатньою мірою від політичної дискримінації
всередині Національного олімпійського комітету.
Міжнародний олімпійський комітет вирішив накласти санкції на білоруських спортивних функціонерів.
Виключити обраних нині членів Виконкому НОК Білорусі з усіх заходів Міжнародного олімпійського комітету,
включно з Олімпійськими іграми. Це стосується, зокрема, пана Олександра Лукашенка як президента НОК і законного представника НОК.
А також пана Віктора Лукашенка як першого віцепрезидента НОК й особи, яка відповідальна за повсякденну діяльність Національного олімпійського комітету Білорусі.
Також МОК заморозить усі платежі НОК Білорусі, а виплати, необхідні для підготовки до Олімпійських ігор, будуть переказувати безпосередньо спортсменам.
МОК також дозволив брати участь у кваліфікації до Олімпійських ігор у Токіо спортсменам, які зіткнулися з репресіями.
Тепер атлети, яких виключили з команд, зможуть взяти участь у світових змаганнях та Олімпіаді,
а чиновники, які наплювали на їхні права, понесуть заслужене покарання.
Історичний момент цього рішення полягає в тому, що нам, Білоруському фонду спортивної солідарності,
вдалося домогтися цього рішення усього за кілька місяців.
Хоча спортивні чиновники заявляли, що ми не маємо права виступати від імені усіх спортсменів. Вони помилялися.
Немає справедливості у світі.
Олександр Лукашенко емоційно відреагував на заборону МОК.
Треба нам звернутися до суду і нехай цей Бах і банда у МОК доведуть, у чому моя вина.
Бо я свою країну захищаю?! За що мене карати!? Щоб я не брав участі у якихось заходах…
Так я участь у цих заходах 25 років не брав, переживу і далі.
Але ви що, зібрали Міжнародний олімпійський комітет, усі країни, обговорили цю тему?
А вони вже там вирішили… Добре, я переживу, але навіщо дітей чіпаєте?
Тим часом, згущуються хмари і над одним з найулюбленіших видів спорту Лукашенка - хокеєм.
За час його правління у Білорусі побудували понад два десятки льодових арен.
Наступного року Білорусь разом з Латвією має стати однією з країн-господарок Чемпіонату світу з хокею. Рига приймати турнір разом з Лукашенком не хоче.
Тепер МОК найближчим часом чекає рішення Міжнародної федерації хокею про можливе перенесення чемпіонату в іншу країну.
На недавніх дебатах у Європарламенті, окрім розширення санкцій та міжнародного розслідування злочинів білоруської влади,
європейські депутати також взяли під приціл і пристрасть Лукашенка - хокей.
Разом з 40 колегами з Європарламенту я відправила лист до Міжнародної федерації хокею,
вимагаючи, щоб Мінськ не приймав Чемпіонат світу з хокею наступного року.
Спорт - не політика. Але в цьому випадку немає виправдань. Ми не можемо грати в хокей з диктатором.
МОК уже запровадив санкції проти голови федерації хокею Білорусі та члена виконкому НОК Дмитра Баскова.
І мова йде не тільки про підтримку режиму Лукашенка. Громадськість і ЗМІ підозрюють, що
Басков міг бути причетним до побиття мінчанина Романа Бондаренка, який після цього помер у лікарні.
Заходів, ухвалених ЄС і державами-членами проти режиму Олександра Лукашенка, недостатньо.
Думаю, зараз ми відчуваємо розчарування від того, що так багато слів, але так мало справ.
Щоб цієї зневіри не стало ще більше, ми повинні зробити те, чого очікують від нас люди, які страждають у Білорусі й борються за свободу.
Я рекомендую створити орган незалежного міжнародного розслідування злочинів, скоєних у контексті виборів президента.
За допомогою експертів-криміналістів необхідно зібрати докази порушень прав людини для майбутніх судових процесів.
Злочинці, силовики, які брали участь у тортурах, і ті, хто віддавав їм накази, повинні бути притягнуті до суду, коли це стане можливим.
За фальсифікацію президентських виборів та репресії проти учасників протестів
на саміті Євросоюзу в жовтні вже вирішили запровадити санкції проти 40 білоруських чиновників.
Через місяць - у листопаді - ЄС ввів санкції проти ще 15 чиновників, включно з самим Олександром Лукашенком.